okay next game
was a strong opponent jacob ends
some his name if i'm correct he's an
untitled player feeder master i'm not
sure from
from the united states but he's a very
strong
blitz player he's rated two six
something here
so not bad at all
yeah we got a
symmetrical english um double fianchetto
line
it's pretty pretty dry position
okay d5 this is the mouse slipper
also says some ingenious idea here
e6
okay if i take here now he would take
with the queen
and maybe it's got some slight activity
i think i
i insert this check here
to get his queen to e7
yeah so of course
very very dry position
d5 interesting move
okay we might try to um
get a rook on the second rank here
um
it's not nothing much you can do here
on both sides actually
draw offered
okay he's trying to squeeze out
something here
um
yeah it should be a draw
it's not really necessary to to
calculate this
okay okay
oh
check
so
bra offered
come on this is really nothing
i only need to take care of always
having king c3 on king c5
other than that it's just nothing
time warning
yeah this is actually repetition yeah
very boring game
but um it was a quite strange move on
him he played there knight c6 i have no
idea what
what what should play after this d4
obviously was
was nothing let's check quickly here
i mean after this you play d5 so maybe
you can
play play d4
can you play d5 immediately
it's a very strange idea here
yeah on e4 he has got knight d5
i don't think i can keep the material
somehow
okay this whole choice of course was a
bit influenced by the ratings and
i lost i lost quite a bit of games
against him so
i wasn't um really um
looking for much more than this um
of course boring position okay i'm a
draw as a draw